welcome back stage we are on the rooftop
of our studio with dr. Robert Lustig you
are also a professor of pediatric
endocrinology I can say big words at
UCSF and college students probably have
some of the worst diets in America they
have the worst diets because college
wants to save money so they provide
cheap food I went to college too and the
food sucked right and that's a problem
so what is what are you trying to
communicate to your students what's like
the big takeaway that you want them to
have when they leave request sadly it's
three words eat real food problem is
ready to get it and if you're in college
really where do you get it right it's
not pizza and beer I promise you man I
know hi to my hopes but you were saying
when we were talking earlier and you and
your wife cook you cook and your wife
bakes and you had some pretty
interesting uh maybe a recipe suggestion
well my wife I can't stop her from
making she's Lutheran I kiss it's a it's
a thing it's a disease that sounds like
a happy problem well yes enough um I
can't stop her but she has experimented
and she has found out that she can take
any recipe any recipe and reduce the
sugar by one-third and it will actually
taste better you can taste them that so
you can taste the opening that can taste
the chocolate chips it actually comes
out better makes sense now if you reduce
it by one half it actually changes the
texture and then it's a problem right
but one-third seems reasonable so the
question is why is there so much sugar
in all the recipes answer food industry
wants you to well if only there was some
cookbook
that had recipes that would have less
sugar and healthy honey funny you should
lead it interesting we have a cookbook
called fat chance cookbook interest
anyway I had no idea how about that I
wrote the text and my colleague and
friend and chef and restaurateur and
food activists Cindy gershon provided
the recipes and they are extraordinarily
low if not no sugar and they are all
real food and they're all prepara belen
30 minutes and they've all been vetted
by a Mount Diablo high school student to
be producible consumable and delicious
within 30 minutes that was my question
are they delicious bottom line i was
like it you can't know until you do but
the food industry would have you not do
because they've convinced you that
cooking's too hard no it's not well
thank you very much for joining us dr.
Robert Lustig thank you and pick up the
fat chance cookbook when you get a
chance and go and see fed up in theaters
this gentleman lenses expertise fed up
we are thanks again thank you